محمود شاب سودانيه يعيش في ليبيا منذ
حوالي 28 سنه يعمل في مجال تقنيه
المعلومات ولكن في هذه الايام تشغله اوضاع
الحرب في السودان عن عمله وتفقده وتركيزه
بسبب خوفه على اهله ووطنه في ازمه طبعا في
الماكل وفي المشروب في التواصل
ونحن خاصه اللي موجودين في بلاد الغربه
القلق عندنا مضاعف جدا لانه ما بنقدر
نتواصل مع كل الاهالي مشاعر محمود لا
تختلف عن غيره من ابناء الجاليه السودانيه
في ليبيا فهم في حاله ترقب دائم ومحاوله
تتبع لكل الاخبار رغم تضاربها وانتشار
عشرات الشائعه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي فيها البشاعات وفيها البخات
القديمه من دول تانيه
فهذا الشيء يؤثر على الناس ويؤثر على
الوطني بشكل كبير تبقى مشاكل انقطاع
الاتصالات والكهرباء على المناطق في
السودان احد المشاكل التي تحرم السودانيين
في ليبيا من التواصل مع عائلاتهم
والاطمئنان عليهم بشكل مستمر
فعانين جدا في ان نتصل بالاهل وتمكنا
الحمد لله واطمئنينا على كثير
وللاسف يعني في الاخبار المش جميله
يعني عندنا عندنا ناس اصيبوا
في ناس ينتقلوا الى رحمه الله سمعنا بعض
الاخبار المؤسفه عن ضحايا في يعني صفوف
الاهل للاسف كانت دكتوره وكانت يعني من
المسعفين وبتحاول تسعف يعني في المصابين
والجرحى لربما عاش افراد الجاليه
السودانيه هنا اوضاعا مشابهه في ليبيا
خلال السنوات الماضيه ما يجعلهم مدركين
للمخاطر الحقيقيه للحروب والخسائر
والاوجاع التي تخلفها
منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات